unterstützt durch den Westen wie bewegt
man Präsident Putin dem Schrecken ein
Ende zu setzen sind mehr Waffen die
richtige Antwort oder gibt es die
Möglichkeit von Verhandlungen und wie
sollte die Bundesregierung agieren
darüber wird in Deutschland inzwischen
Teil sehr heftig diskutiert ein Jahr
Krieg gegen die Ukraine wie schafft man
Frieden unser Thema in der phönix-
herzlich willkommen ich darf Ihnen meine
Gäste vorstellen bei uns ist Natalia
priornicka sie ist
Politikwissenschaftlerin und
Mitbegründerin der Allianz ukrainische
Organisationen
herzlich willkommen Prof Peter Brandt
Historiker er hat an der FernUniversität
in Hagen gelehrt er ist Sozialdemokrat
sein Vater war Willy Brandt und Peter
Brandt hat die von Sarah Wagenknecht und
Alice Schwarzer initiierte Petition
Manifest für den Frieden unterzeichnet
ganz herzlich willkommen Prof
Militärhistoriker an der Universität
Potsdam und herzlich willkommen Prof
Wolfgang Merkel Politikwissenschaftler
sein Schwerpunkt ist die
Demokratisierung er war am
Wissenschaftszentrum Berlin und an der
Humboldt-Universität tätig und im April
hat er den offenen Brief an Kanzler
Scholz unterzeichnet der hat sich gegen
die Lieferung weiterer schwerer Waffen
ausgesprochen der Brief mit all sein
unterzeichnen Frau prijunitzka ein Jahr
dieser schreckliche Krieg was ist was
hat sich für sie getan geändert wie ist
dieses Jahr für sie gewesen
ich muss sie gleich korrigieren nicht
ein Jahr für mich sondern neun Jahre
russischen Krieg gegen die Ukraine mit
Annexion der Grimm und dem Krieg in
dornpass war der Beginn des Krieges
gesetzt und mit 24
Februar 22 wurde der Krieg ausgedient
auf das ganze Land auf die ganze Ukraine
was hat sich verändert ich glaube wir
haben alle
eine Zäsur erlebt die keiner so geahnt
hätte in dem Ausmaß
wir haben eine unglaubliche da
Solidarität der Menschen in Deutschland
erlebt auf der ganzen Welt in Europa
gegenüber den Menschen die aus der
Ukraine flüchten mussten aufgrund des
Krieges und wir haben viele Umdenken es
wurden viele Umdenkprozesse angestoßen
die jetzt auch weiter fortgeführt werden
schauen natürlich noch mal genau darauf
was ich jetzt noch beim ändern muss
natürlich ausführlich Herr brand was ist
für sie die größte Lehre die sie ziehen
nach dem einen Jahr dieses Angriffskrieg
auch wenn Frau präsidenz gehört zu Recht
sagt eigentlich hat dieser Krieg ja
schon viel früher angefangen
naja
darüber könnte man jetzt streiten ob es
einfach die Fortsetzung dessen ist also
in der in den Jahren davor war ja
sozusagen die innerer ukraineische
Komponente sehr viel stärker aber ich
will das jetzt gar nicht bestreiten
nun
ich habe bis zum Schluss
ist für sehr unwahrscheinlich gehalten
dass dieser Angriff einfach nicht für
unmöglich aber für sehr unwahrscheinlich
gehalten und habe war davon ausgegangen
da wird eine druckkulisse aufgebaut und
die
die wichtigste Lehre scheint mir zu sein
dass wir in der
internationalen Ordnung in der
Staatenordnung in der wir leben wird
nicht davor gefeit sind das solche
Dinge geschehen das heißt unser Haupt
Interesse müsste in die Richtung gehen
nicht nur den Krieg zu beenden sondern
auch eine stabile
sicherheitsordnung in der nördlichen
Hemisphäre
zu errichten und die wir dachten dass
wir sie hätten ja also das konnte man
schon da konnte man schon viele Fragen
zeigen setzen nicht erst unmittelbar vor
dem Krieg aber es hat sozusagen im nach
dem oder und mit dem historischen
Umbruch
1989 91 hat es ja Ansätze gegeben die
dann nicht weiter verfolgt worden sind
was würden Sie sagen wenn sie jetzt
zurückschauen am 24
februar vor einem Jahr die Angriffe
Russlands auch auf Kiew was war das für
sie was war das wie schauen Sie zurück
auf diesen Jahres also auf diesen
Angriff also für mich war es eigentlich
wie
für Herrn Brand dass ich es auch für
unwahrscheinlich gehalten habe ich
erinnere mich an einen heute journal
Interview vielleicht was ich nicht zehn
Tage vor Ausbruch des Krieges dem ich
auch sagte naja die Diplomatie hat immer
eine Chance und wir alle wissen nicht
wie diese Verhandlungen diese Reise
diplomatiert wirklich ausgeht naja
einige Geheimdienstkreise wussten mehr
aber ich lese leider nicht die Berichte
dass hier und
war da auf meine allgemeine Sichtweise
angewiesen und ich habe es auch
eigentlich für unwahrscheinlich habe es
auch als druckknüsse aber auch weil ich
zu wenig wusste aber es ist also für
mich ist der entscheidende Punkt dass
wir eigentlich seit 30 Jahren lang den
Krieg aus dem referenzraum von Politik
und Gesellschaft rauszukliniert haben
da war aber nie draußen wenn wir an die
Jugoslawien Tschetschenien und so weiter
wir haben aber meine Sachen zu uns eine
unglaublichen Illusion hingegeben dass
wir natürlich das nicht wollen aber das
was machen wir eigentlich wenn andere zu
diesem Mittel greifen und da haben wir
uns oft einen schlank nicht immer kann
man näher drüber reden kurz darauf
Afghanistan schlanken Fuß gemacht und
das ist uns am 24 Februar massiv auf die
Füße gefallen denn der Punkt war ja
eigentlich nicht der Fehler war nicht
dass man Russland die Hand ausgestreckt
hat dass man versucht hat mit allen
Versuchen Russland einzubinden letztlich
in einem Weltordnung sondern dass man
keine
vorausschaukelt getroffen hat was
passiert eigentlich wenn das nicht
klappt und da sind wir auf ja ich sag
mal jetzt ein bisschen runtergelassenen
Hosen erwischt worden sind müsste nicht
eine Lehre nach aus diesem Angriff sein
dass wir alle Putin komplett
unterschätzt haben
der falsch eingeschätzt haben
ich würde sagen wir haben ihn falsch
eingeschätzt aber genauso falsch finde
ich wenn man jetzt irgendwelche Aufsätze
von ihm hervorzieht und sagt ihr hättet
es wissen müssen hier ist ein
Revisionist am Werke der die Grenzen so
verschieben will dass das neue Russland
in etwa der Sowjetunion entspricht die
halte das für
kompletten und sind aber was Herr
neitzelt sagt da ist sicherlich ein
Punkt da drin also dass wir uns
insbesondere in Westeuropa in
Deutschland so und so weil wir noch
diese furchtbare Vergangenheit hatten in
der Zwischenzeit eigentlich ganz gut
eingerichtet haben wir haben uns
eingerichtet und konzentriert unsere
Gesellschaft zu demokratisieren die
Gesellschaft friedlicher zu machen die
Brücken dort zu bauen
Außenpolitik war eigentlich ein
sekundäres Portfolio im
Regierungskabinett und das hat sich
tatsächlich jetzt verändert die Frage
ist aber in welche Richtung es sich
verändern wird eine Dominanz einer
sozusagen
waffengestützten Außenpolitik die würde
ich niemanden wünschen und schon gar
nicht Frau Brönner ist das auch wenn man
der Ukraine und auch den baltischen
Staaten eben zugehört hätte hätte man
vielleicht Dinge anders einschätzen
können dass das Gefühl dass sie haben
dass man ihnen nicht zugehört hat mit
all den Warnungen die es gab ich glaube
uns bringt es nicht viel weiter in
konstruktiven Sinne jetzt darüber
nachzudenken weil was hätte passieren
können sondern was wir zukunftsgerichtet
machen können und ich habe unseren Herrn
Professoren auch zugehört und hätte mir
auch jetzt gedacht was warum hat man
eigentlich das nicht geglaubt ist oder
eher geringer eingeschätztes Putin
angreift wenn man sich tatsächlich diese
Geschehnisse der letzten acht Jahre
angeguckt hat mit dem mit der Annektion
der Creme mit der am Anfang des Krieges
in dornbas mit Repressionen in Russland
also Auslöschung also Repression gegen
die russische Position Verbot der
deutschen Organisation die mit der
Zivilgesellschaft
kooperiert haben im engen über viele
viele Jahre und auch den Bruch des
Souveränität Deutschlands mit dem
tiergartenmord zum Beispiel
19.2019 oder den Hackerangriffen auf den
Deutschen Bundestag die nachweislich da
waren und dann natürlich mit dem wo all
die Truppen von der Grenze standen noch
vor der ukrainischen Grenze noch in
April 20 20 21
das waren schon bereits 80.000 Truppen
die da waren und darüber wurde so ein
bisschen gesprochen was kann das
bedeuten und dann diese
April 20 22
20 22 mit 200.000 Soldaten ich warum ich
das sage weil ich letztes Jahr am 14
Februar in die Ukraine geflogen bin weil
es mir so alles schrecklich erschienen
und meine Familie noch in der Ukraine
war und ich wusste wenn es passieren
dass wir einen Plan haben müssen und ich
bin überrascht genau das war dann nach
dem Angriff
müssten wir dann auch nach Deutschland
kommen zusammen also die Frage so was
lernen wir daraus wenn wir merken wir
haben bestimmte Sachen nicht richtig
eingeschätzt das war eben meine Frage
auch nach der wie man Putin einschätzt
ist ja auch eine Frage wie man jetzt
damit umgeht hinein sind wie
es ist kein Frieden keine Verhandlung in
Sicht auch wenn es auf allen Seiten
versucht wird um es ganz klar einfach
noch mal zu fragen sind die
Waffenlieferung im Moment die richtige
Antwort um diesen Krieg zu beenden also
aus meiner Sicht ja das wird ja ein auch
in der Runde unterschiedlich bewertet
aus meiner Sicht Jahren die große die
eine Million Dollar Frage ist ja wie
können erreichen keiner von uns weiß das
weil keiner von uns kann in putinskopf
schauen und kann letztlich bestimmen
unter welchen Bedingungen wäre Putin
bereit den Kampf zu beenden
da kann man verschiedene historische
Beispiele wann kriege enden aber
letztlich hängt das von der Logik Putins
ab und das ist genau auch die Verbindung
zu ihrer Frage vorhin wir alle machen
meistens den Fehler dass wir natürlich
diesen Krieg aus unserer Brille
betrachten mit unserer Sichtweise
demokratisch geprägt und so weiter und
wir haben enormes enormes Defizit das
aus russischer Sicht zu sehen die
wenigsten von uns sprechen russisch die
wenigsten uns waren in diesem Land
kennen das Land wirklich wir haben wenig
Kompetenz bisschen Kompetenz gibt es
aber wenig und damit machen wir immer
einen einen Denkfehler weil wir
eigentlich aus unserer Sicht
argumentieren also es macht auch aus
wirtschaftlichen Sinne und das müsste
doch und so sollte und das ist ja auch
die Kritik von vielen Freunden von mir
die viel mehr über Russland verstehen an
sich die sagen ihr versteht eigentlich
Russland nicht wann wart ihr denn mal da
und ja ihr macht große Reden über
Russland aber das Land nie das heißt und
Putin hat eine andere Logik und deswegen
glaube ich wir können haben
unterschiedliche gesichtspeisen sie
sagen das hilft wir müssen weiter diese
Wahl würde ich sagen
nicht mehr und dann brauchen wir nicht
über Frieden drin okay das ist auch das
was Annalena beerbock bei der
vorversammlung der UNO sagt die sagte
wenn Russland das Kämpfen einstellt dann
endet dieser Krieg wenn die Ukraine das
Kämpfen einstellt dann endet die Ukraine
Herr Brand sie haben diesen Brief
unterzeichnet von Sahra Wagen nicht und
alles schwarzer den haben sehr viele
Menschen über eine halbe Million
Menschen unterzeichnen die sagen wir
müssen auch Verhandlungen setzen und
nicht weiter Waffen liefern warum denken
Sie das Waffenlieferungen nicht helfen
das steht da nicht drin da steht drin
wir wenden uns gegen die Eskalation der
Waffenlieferung ist was anderes
und ich würde auch nicht für einen Stopp
der Waffenlieferung plädieren
es geht darum
wie man wo man den Schwerpunkt setzt und
ob man meint dass sozusagen man alles
das liefern kann was gewünscht wird also
dieses
eskalationsrisiko und das hat nichts mit
dass wir hier vor Angst schlottern also
sind Sie einverstanden sind aber andere
die also vor Wagen nicht sieht das schon
anders
das ist ja geschehen also der der das
man
andert worden ich glaube Sie haben es
auch gesagt haben Einzel das ist
zunächst mal eine symbolische Sache man
müsste wahrscheinlich 1000 Panzer
liefern damit man die
militärische Situation der der Ukraine
wirklich
verbessern könnte
aber jetzt wird ja geredet über
Flugzeuge über Unterseeboote und über
Streubomben jetzt also das ist das
weswegen von der escal ich habe ja den
den Aufruf nicht geschrieben ich habe
ihn unterschrieben jeder der 70 die das
gemacht haben würde ist etwas anders
formulieren aber nur mal erklärt was da
drin steht und was da nicht drin steht
sie fragen warum sie ihren ab diesen
Appell nicht an Herrn Putin gerichtet
haben
wir können doch nicht zu einem Diktator
das ist lächerlich wir leben in diesem
Land wir sind Bürger dieses Landes die
Regierung hier ist uns als
repräsentierten verpflichtet sich zu
erklären das muss unser Adressat sein
ein Krieg Verbrecher einem Diktator ein
Brief zu stehen das ist politisch
versucht eine ganze ein ganzes Land
vollkommen voll ein Angreifer der gerade
Städte auslöscht Menschen zu Tausenden
umbringt und zwar schreiben ist doch
unsinnig warum ist es Unsinn
das wäre doch ein klarer Punkt eine
Position wenn wir tatsächlich darüber
reden dass es um die Idee Eskalation
sich handelt dann wäre Putin der
richtige Adresse hat ja aber also
eine Gerechtigkeit völkerrechtlichen
Perspektive natürlich der richtige
Adresse aber wirklich das ist etwas
bewegen würde das
empfänglich ist und alle sagen er ist ja
für nichts empfänglicher er will ja auch
ganz klar nicht verhandeln also so ein
Brief aus Deutschland wäre doch für ihn
ich glaube so ein Brief aus Deutschland
ist auch viel an die deutsche Politik
adressiert und so ein Brief an Putin
würde auch viel in deutschen in
Deutschland in der deutschen Politik
verändern das wäre auch ein klares
Signal dass in der Bevölkerung ein
breites Verständnis in den
intellektuellen Kreisen ein breites
Verständnis darüber gibt wo die
deeskalationsursache
sitzt aber das Putin der Aggressor ist
wird ja hier von keiner Seite bestrichen
im übrigen ich wollte nur mal sagen
einwerfen also ich habe
im vergangenen Frühjahr
beim Ostermarsch in Frankfurt gesprochen
auf Einladung und unter habe ich den
Rückzug der Truppen der russischen
Truppen gefordert also es ist nicht so
dass das nicht angesprochen wird aber
das ist eine andere Aktion es geht hier
um unsere Regierung und um die Frage wie
die sich in der Sache verhalten soll es
geht auch darum da muss ich tatsächlich
noch mal nachhaken weil in diesem Brief
wird Russland nicht als Angreifer
benannt das wird nicht klar definiert
dass da nicht zwei gerade
Kriegsparteien sind die sich gegenseitig
betrügen sondern es gibt ein Angreifer
der das andere Land überfallen hat er
Angreifer ist oder muss auch klar aus
dem Schreiben sein so ist so klar ist es
und eindeutig nicht so dass wir beide
haben uns ja an vielen Stellen geäußert
auch ausführlicher als Personen und
insofern müssen sie nicht
wir sprechen auch über
deeskalationsmöglichkeiten und ich
glaube diese Adressaten an denen diese
Nachrichten diese messages gesandt
werden sind entscheidend sind sehr sehr
wichtig verstehen Sie dass das sehr auf
dass dieser der Brief hat ja sehr viel
Kritik hervorgerufen gerade aus bei
Menschen aus der Ukraine die hier leben
verstehen sie das dass das ein falscher
Zungenschlag ist dass man zu wenig auf
die Ukraine eingegangen ist zu wenig die
Perspektive der ukrainischen Bevölkerung
eingenommen hat
nein also ist vollkommen klar und wir
sollten hier nicht ein eine Strohpuppe
aufbauen dass wir einig sind in der
Einschätzung der Krieg ist alleine von
dem putinen Regime zu verantworten putin
ist der Agressor völkerrechtlich gibt es
nicht einen Deutz Zweifel daran und
daran haben die Unterzeichner oder die
formuliere diese Briefe überhaupt nie
einen Zweifel gelassen und ich glaube
auch dass unsere Debatte jetzt an diesen
Briefen herumzuhermen leuteisieren ist
jetzt jedesmal Russland tatsächlich
genau weiter in Deutschland und im
Moment gibt es sozusagen auf einmal die
einen sagen ihr seid Kriegstreiber die
anderen sagen ihr seid so verpasst sie
wissen also wie sehen sie diese Debatte
ist das eine ist das auch eine naive
Debatte von Menschen echt zu wenig
Ahnung haben davon worauf es in dem
Krieg ankommt also alles schwarz als
jetzt vielleicht nicht die große
Expertin Sicherheitspolitik aber die
auch nicht für die Ukraine nein aber der
Punkt ist doch dass wir eigentlich der
Gesellschaft zusehen können wie sie um
Argumente ringt und diese Erklärung und
gegenerklärung und wie auch immer werden
auch emotional geführt es geht ja auch
um was aber das also Deutschland ist
eben so nicht also alles andere wäre
merkwürdig wenn es diese Briefe nicht
gäbe wäre es merkwürdig wenn wir auf die
Umfragen schauen dann sind ja sind wir
eingespaltenes Land und wenn wir die aus
den Ost-West-Vergleich sehen da sind wir
auch eingespeichert ist dann es gibt
unterschiedliche Sichtweisen viele
halten die USA für den für den
eigentlichen dämmern andere sehen dann
eher eher Putin als den eigentlich in
dem und wir haben ein unterschiedliches
Verhältnis zu Waffen zu warten Lieferung
es ist ohnehin erstaunlich muss ich aus
meiner Sicht sagen ich bin ja zum ersten
Mal in meinem Leben eher mit mehr als
Meinung ist ein ganz neuer Erfahrung für
mich weil ähm den Weg den die SPD auch
die SPD aber gerade den Grünen
zurückgelegt haben also ich habe gar
nichts gegen solche Briefe man kann
zustimmen man kann sie ablehnen das ist
in der Demokratie so man kann auch es
Schlaf ablehnen das gehört dazu wenn man
sich öffentlich äußert und inwieweit das
das Regierungshandeln beeinflusst Herrn
Scholz und Herrn Schmidt und so weiter
ist ja ohnehin das weiß der
Politikwissenschaftler besser als ich
dann fraglich
ob überhaupt eine Initiative der
Bundesrepublik ob wir überhaupt als
Bundesrepublik da entscheidend sind kann
man auch in Frage stellen das ist ein
Sinnbild stark um die eigene
Befindlichkeit weil wir alle das man
will sich verordnen positionieren genau
aber es lässt doch die Ukraine
eigentlich total außer acht das zeigt
doch es geht doch viel man hat doch viel
zu wenig den Fokus auf die Menschen in
der Ukraine
vergangenen Wochenende auf der Münster
Sicherheitskonferenz da also die gesamte
Szene mit Ausnahme von Herrn Warwick ist
sich komplett einig die Ukraine zu
unterstützen Waffen zu liefern das ist
eine Einigkeit auch der der Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sich mit Sicherheitspolitik
beschäftigen die die schon erstaunlich
ist so und die große Masse würde ich
sagen der der Äußerungen die man sagen
beruflich wird der journalistischen
Kollegen gehen auch in diese Richtung
also dass wir zu wenig Empathie mit der
Ukraine haben auch zu wenig Stimmen es
gäbe die Ukraine mit Waffen zu
unterstützen das kann man glaube ich
nicht sagen es gibt auch die anderen
Stellen wie finden sie empfinden Sie es
denn seit diesem seit dieser ganzen
Diskussion um diesen Brief das ist ja
jetzt einfach noch mal im Moment stärker
geworden das ist eine sehr berechtigte
Frage es gibt viel Unterstützung es gibt
tatsächlich da würde ich Ihnen auch
zustimmen es gibt sehr viel
Unterstützung in diese Richtung aber es
gibt auch ein tiefes Entsetzen wenn
solche Briefe wie von alles schwarz und
Wagenknecht also solche manifeste die
eigentlich keine manifeste der des
Frieden sind weil diese manifeste
sichern einfach kein nachhaltigen
Frieden die können kein nachhaltigen
Frieden sichern und das ruft Sohn
Entsetzen hervor wenn sowas kommt weil
das zeigt noch mal und betont jedes Mal
wie wenig man die Ukraine kennt wie
wenig Kenntnisse über das Land gibt aber
nicht nur über die Ukraine sondern auch
über die Staaten des Baltikums über die
imperialen Anstrebungen Russlands wie
die Beziehungen zum Beispiel zwischen
Russland und Polen sind warum haben sich
Menschen haben sie sich auch hinterfragt
warum zum Beispiel baltische Staaten und
Polen so reagieren wie sie reagieren
seit acht Jahren bitten Sie auch darum
um mehr Sicherheit der Kredit auch für
die Region ich überlege was ich denke
hören wir da auch genau zu das ist so
meine Frage und das war ihre
Eingangsfrage hat sich da äh dahin getan
ich glaube da gab es ein Wandel aber
mich würde auch ähm also ich wünschte
mir mehr mehr Kenntnisse über die
Ukraine und mehr Reflektion Sie wollen
direkt vielleicht ich bin jetzt mal zu
spitzen es gibt und an der waffenfrage
noch mal
erklären es gibt zwei unterschiedliche
Positionen die eine Position sagt wir
müssen mehr Waffen liefern wir müssen
die Ukraine instand setzen diesen Krieg
zu gewinnen je mehr liefern je bessere
und schärfere Waffen umso schneller wird
der Krieg beendet sein das ist eine
völlig legitime Position wir wissen
nicht ob sie eintrifft die andere
Position denkt ebenfalls nach wie kann
dieser Krieg so beendet werden dass
möglichst wenig Menschen sterben das
möglichst wenig Städte zerstört werden
und das Land und die sagt es gibt im
Hintergrund ein Diktator ein
gewaltherrschen Moskau und der hat ein
unendlich größeres Potenzial an Menschen
an Soldaten und ist ruchlose diese
Menschen in den Krieg zu schicken als es
eine demokratische Ukraine kann und
deshalb
denken vielleicht ein kleiner Punkt wir
denken nicht mit das ist sozusagen wenn
wir sagen man kann diesen Krieg gegen
Russland nicht gewinnen das ist ja auch
das was auch die Unterzeichnerin der
immer ganz klar sagen dann heißt doch
dass das dann wir eigentlich jetzt schon
aufgeben müssen dann muss die Ukraine
aufgeben dann muss mal darin ausgehen da
muss Georgina doch das ist es doch dann
ist genauso ist das
zurzeit wollen wir natürlich auch die
Militärexperten dazu haben also ich
würde den Pass insofern zustimmen das
zurzeit nicht zu erkennen ist wie die
Ukraine
ihr gesamtes Territorium mit
militärischen Mitteln befreien soll so
das ist der besten weiter Waffen gut das
ist immer das sind viele ist aber die
die Bäume wachsen nicht in den Himmel da
müssen wir realistisch sein und wenn man
mit naturleuten spricht hinter der
kulissenden sehen die das eigentlich
auch nicht und außer bei vielleicht ähm
der auch in diese Richtung ging es gibt
eine Möglichkeit die Krim zu erobern ich
sehe das nicht und ich sehe da würde ich
auch den Brief widersprechen ich glaube
die Waffenlieferungen sind nicht so zu
sehen dass die Ukraine in der Lage wären
auch wenn es solche Äußerungen gibt die
zurückzuoben da würde ich einfach sagen
es ist militärisch zurzeit nach allem
was wir wissen schlicht nicht möglich es
geht darum gibt es die Ukraine noch gibt
sie nicht oder ist die Ukraine überhaupt
in der Lage in einer Position zu kommen
dass wir verhandeln können dass die
Ukraine zum Beispiel die Landbrücke
zurückerobert das sind
landwirtschaftlich besonders wichtige
Territorien um überhaupt dann sagen kann
als Staat kann sie überhaupt so
existieren das ist jetzt sehr schwierig
und dann ist ja die Frage wenn man jetzt
ein Friedensverhandlungen denkt man
sollte sicherlich jetzt nicht nur auf
die chinesischen Pläne warten sondern
auch eine eigene Position entwickeln
aber wie will ich mit jemand das wäre
meine meine Frage mit jemand verhandeln
der aus meiner Sicht überhaupt nicht
verhandeln will also für Putin gibt es
überhaupt keinen Grund null nada jetzt
zu verhandeln warum nicht aus
militärischen Gründen hat mobilisiert er
sagt ich zwinge der Ukraine meinen Krieg
auf ich werde diesen Krieg gewinnen der
Westen ist schwach auch wegen solchen
manifesten die sicherlich Putin sich so
wahrgenommen werden der besten ist
gespannt also aus seiner Sicht wenn wir
jetzt wenn Bundeskanzler Scholz
jetzt eine Initiative starten würde nie
und nimmer ich weiß es nicht aber ich
würde sagen nie und nimmer geht Putin
darauf ein oder China darauf ein weil
sie sagen
Russland wird diesen Krieg gewinnen
zumindest insofern gewinnen dass Sie
mindestens den gesamten frei kämpfen und
dann ist wieder ein neuer stand dann
wissen wir nicht wie Putin reagieren
deswegen wäre meine Position wir müssen
Waffenlieferung wenn man mal realistisch
ist ähm
geht es darum überlegt die Ukraine und
da da müssen wir ehrlich sein und das
ist 50 50 würde ich sagen und ist die
Ukraine vielleicht in der Lage die
Landbrücke zurückzuholen wenn wir die
Ukraine darin nicht unterstützen wird es
vielleicht in einem halben Jahr eine
völlig andere militärische Situationen
geben und dann reden wir nicht über
Frieden sondern eigentlich
sollte hier Putin nehmen wir mal an es
gibt diese Rücken und warum sollte Putin
sagen okay habt ihr zurückerobert jetzt
will ich verhandeln wenn er weitere
eskalationsmöglichkeiten hat wir trauen
ihn mit Recht alle möglichen Verbrechen
zu warum glauben wir dann hebt er die
Hände und sagt
schnell die Ukraine einnehmen und da war
die Ukraine stärker und die NATO ist ja
nun noch viel stärker warum sollte er
sich damit annehmen
ich habe verloren aber die Frage ob man
einen Zustand erreicht der defacto
wahrscheinlich einen Waffenstillstand
wahrscheinlicher macht indem du über die
Ukraine sich wirklich verteidigen kann
aber ich würde gerne die ukrainische
sich da noch mal raus sehen wo wäre
also was ist das wichtigste für die
Ukraine das wichtigste für die Ukraine
ist dass es Waffen weitergeliefert
werden und es ist eine vorausschauende
Strategie in der Hinsicht der
Unterstützung gibt das ist durch die
Politik eine Strategie geschaffen wird
wenn Person befreit wird das ist danach
Person auch gesichert werden kann und da
würde ich auch wenn man über die Krim
redet ist das ein Punkt wo sie sagen die
müssen die muss auf jeden Fall wieder
Ukrainisch werden oder gibt es auch
Stimmen wo man sagt wenn es nicht anders
geht wenn das unser Preis wäre ein
nachhaltigen Frieden in der Ukraine eine
nachhaltigen Frieden in Europa wird das
dann geben wenn die Ukraine diesen bei
diesem Krieg gewinnt und ein gewinnt
bedeutet dass die Ukraine zu ihren
Staatsgrenzen von 1991 zurückkehrt was
nämlich bedeuten würde dass es
Wiederherstellung des internationalen
Rechts ist weil wir in einem
internationalen Rechtssystem leben also
das bedeutet 23 Februar
29 würde ihnen nicht reichen das würde
das würde mir nicht reichen und es würde
glaube ich geht es nicht um mich es geht
um die Menschen die in diesen besatzsten
und okkupierten Gebieten wohnen und ich
finde ich mir ich zog da immer zusammen
wenn man drücke Eroberung immer sagt
weil es ist nicht rückerobert und die
Ukraine erobert nicht zurück sie befreit
diese Regionen sie befreit auch Menschen
die dort in diesen Regionen leben und
wenn wir darüber sprechen zu welchen
Grenzen man zurückkehren sollte worüber
wir verhandeln da geht es tatsächlich um
Menschen und wir sehen was russische
Truppen was russische Mächte in der
Ukraine machen
die jetzt als Besatzer dort als Besatzer
sind da kann da ist es für mich sollten
es genau richtig da würde ich sie ja
unterstützen es sollte so sein aber ob
das realistisch ist ist wieder eine
andere Frage ne und was die kosten und
Opfer sind
was würden Sie sagen also wie soll man
wie kann man der agieren würden sie von
der Ukraine erwarten dass sie den
rechtlich völkerrechtlich war
die Besetzung der Krim durch Russland
ein Vergehen also war sozusagen gegen
das Völkerrecht
ein Verbrechen aber sie können doch
nicht leugnen dass die Ukraine seit
ihrer Unabhängigkeit ein politisch
gespaltenes Land war es war woran machen
Sie das fest Herr brand was sind Wasser
machen Sie das fest dass die Ukraine
also wenn wir die Präsidentenwahlen
angucken
in dieser ganzen Periode dann zeigt sich
eine massive Spaltung zwischen dem
Westen und der Mitte des Landes
einerseits und dem Süden und dem Osten
des Landes andererseits des Paradoxe ist
das Putin wahrscheinlich mit seinem
Krieg dazu beigetragen hat diese innere
Spaltung
gewissermaßen ich will nicht sagen
aufzuheben aber
außerordentlich ab Bildern also diese
ganz dieses ganze russische Manöver ist
ein Desaster aus russischer Sicht diese
ganze militärische Aktion
genau ich verstehe das auch noch nicht
ganz
also
die die Idee die er hatte war doch in
kürzester Frist
nach Kia vorzustoßen und
die Regierung abzusetzen ob er sie jetzt
umbringen wollte oder nicht und die
Ukraine zu erledigen dass das ist
die Frage was wie man jetzt zu einem
Frieden kommen nicht das ist ja die
große Frage sie sagen ja ganz klar diese
diese Gebiete sind besetzt
sind sie besetzt und die Menschen wollen
auch nicht unter dieser russischen
Besetzung leben ja das wir wissen nicht
ganz genau was die Menschen in der
Ostukraine wollen also entschuldigung
aber da muss ich tatsächlich also wenn
man sich die Umfragen von 2014 noch
anguckt wenn wir wirklich so gucken und
tatsächlich einfach so abstimmungsbild
der Ukraine uns anschauen da wollte
keiner zu Russland gehören da wurde
expliziert danach auch gefragt ob man
sich und zugehörig fühlt es gab es eine
Propaganda die über Jahre hinweg
durchgezogen wurde leider auch in
Deutschland auch erfolgreich war dass
Menschen die Russisch sprechen Russen
auch sind was nicht stimmt was wir
mittlerweile auch wissen dass es nicht
stimmt es gab es auch Äußerungen dass
man auch sich dem westlichen Werten auch
ihr zugehören zugehörig fühlt und da
finde ich das auch zu sagen dass da ein
tiefgespaltenes Land ist wo ich sie
wirklich Frage dran machen wenn eure
Meinung 2014 war in hardiff in sapricia
hinten Internet gab es Demonstrationen
die für europäische Werte waren wo
Menschen zusammengeschlossen gestanden
haben ja aber ich sage ja auch dass das
diese ursprüngliche Spaltung des Landes
gerade durch die russische Aggression an
Bedeutung verloren hat umso stärker dass
die Ukraine als ein Volk natürlich noch
mal umso stärker auch alle diese Opfer
bringen damit sie ihn Freiheit leben
können das ist ja das worum es geht und
jetzt noch mal die Frage
Friedensverhandlungen Waffenstillstand
was würde das denn bedeuten und wie soll
es aussehen er mag wenn sie sagen also
wie wie stellen Sie sich das vor dass
wenn sie sagen wir wollen müssen wir
auch Verhandlungen setzen wir haben zu
wenig politische Fantasie wenn wir in
einer einfachen Reihenfolge denken sagen
erstens und es erinnert mich gerade zu
ein universitäre pro Seminare ersten
müssen wir neue
rückgewinne das angestammten
ukrainischen
Territoriums haben damit verändern wir
unsere Position am verhandlungs- vorher
wird Putin mit uns nicht richtig
verhandeln also diese Sequenz
diese Sequenz ist meine Meinung falsch
es muss gleichzeitig laufen nicht erst
die Kriegslogik und wenn die Kriegslogik
ausgespielt wir wissen nicht wer der
Gewinner ist dann verhandeln wir der
entscheidende Akteur sind die
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika gibt es
überhaupt keine Frage wenn die
Amerikaner sagen und wenn Republikaner
an die Macht kommen kann das durchaus
der Fall sein wenn Amerikaner sagen zur
Regierung in Kiew wir müssen diesen
fürchterlichen Potentaten was anbieten
und wir können nicht sagen die gesamte
Creme muss wieder zurückerobert werden
Putin muss mit seinen Truppen das Land
verlassen haben da gibt's fast nichts
mehr zu verhandeln es muss ja verhandelt
werden dass er das Land verlässt und die
USA sind der entscheidende Spieler und
wenn die USA in einer Art und Weise
irgendein Verständnis mit China zustande
bringen das China als eine Garantie
macht in dem eigenen Interesse hier
gibt es eine Arena zu fahren
also er Merkel die natürlich ist nicht
nur die USA entscheidender Faktor
sondern vor allem Russland also wenn die
USA etwas anbietet und Putin nicht will
dann passiert überhaupt nichts und ich
halte es für eine totale Illusion zu
glauben dass Putin jetzt der jetzigen
Lage deswegen ohne militärische
Niederlagen ohne zu Drohnen ist eine
Armee zusammenbricht zu Verhandlungen
bereit ist das wissen wir beide nicht
ich auch nicht ich halte es auch für
eine absolute Illusion zu glauben dass
die Chinesen von uns irgendwie
beeinflussbar wären die zeigen uns ein
Vogel und sagen ähm das ist auch sie
verfolgen ihr eigenes Interesse also man
kann natürlich man kann natürlich ganz
kurz in den Gedanken noch zu Ende sagen
die Regierung muss auch die
diplomatische Karte ziehen da würde doch
jeder in der Regierung sagen ja was
glaubt in dem was unser Botschafter von
Geier in Moskau macht wurde in der Nase
den ganzen Tag oder so und natürlich
gibt es dort Kontakte natürlich versucht
man ständig was
gefahren ist hat man ja auch die Russen
informiert dass auf jeden Fall es kann
auch gar nicht öffentlich laufen weil
natürlich kann kann jetzt der der Leiter
Planungsstab vom Auswärtigen Amt nicht
sagen wir wir entwickeln mal was so also
ich glaube das ist ein ein Mist Trust
der Regierung die sie da formulieren
dass sie glauben diplomatisch wird
nichts passieren also ich glaube alle
von uns haben doch den Wunsch dass
dieser ich sag jetzt mal der Scheiß
Krieg endet und das natürlich Diplomatie
immer ein Mittel ist aber das gehören
zwei dazu und als es Drucker wird wissen
wir doch nicht die Lage sind für mich so
ein bisschen wie im April 1915 aus für
dich gab es da auch schon
Friedensbewegungen aber zufrieden das
wissen wir gehören immer zwei und die
Frage ist die eine Million Dollar Frage
unter welchen Bedingungen ist Putin
bereit wie auch immer zu sagen wir
einigen uns irgendwie auf einen
Unentschieden und so würden Sie denn
sein dass sich die Position der Ukraine
im sehr gestärkt hat weil es die ganzen
Waffenlieferungen gibt das wäre doch ein
Argument wieder dafür
ohne die USA wird die Ukraine nicht mehr
geben wenn sie sich auf die Europäer
verlassen hätte würde ich die Ukraine
nicht geben das ist eine bittere
Erkenntnis und die Stärke Europas
erkennen wir ja daran dass 450 Millionen
EU Europäer sich nicht trauen 90 Panzer
zu liefern ohne die USA nicht Europa es
will ist bei allem was sie tun ist
sicherheitspolitisch ist das dann doch
immer wieder die Frage wenn wir über die
Verhandlungen sprechen dann sollten wir
auch über die Verhandlungen aus also
sich eine gestärkten Ukraine aussprechen
und was man machen könnte dass man auch
mehr Druck auf die Eliten ausübt wenn
wir aber jetzt die Rede von Putin von
vorgestern angucken dann sehen wir wenn
der Start den USA hat Vertrag
aufgekündigt wird was bedeutet das für
uns was sind das für Zeichen und da
frage ich mich Herr Merkel wir sehen Sie
die Verhandlungen wir sehen Sie diesen
Weg sie plädieren dafür wie sehen sie
denen ich sehe schlecht wenn die Logik
weiter so gespielt wird dass die Ukraine
in einer strategisch besser
Situation sich befinden muss
andererseits würde Putin nicht
verhandeln dann muss auch diskutiert
werden kann man das humanitär und
ethisch akzeptieren kann man es
akzeptieren dass 100.000 200.000 mehr
Menschen sterben bevor die
Verhandlungsposition
500 Menschen mehr sterben wenn diese
Waffen nicht kommen können sich Menschen
in der Ukraine nicht verurteilen
will
auch nicht verhandeln mit
maximalistischen Positionen kann man
nicht fahren
es wurde verhandelt
hat gesagt dass man
von Odessa wurde am gleichen Tag
bombardiert und es ging es um Getreide
Auslieferungen
gesagt dass man nahe an einem solchen
Waffenstillstand war es waren die USA
und London
israelische Premiere halluziniert und
das ist alles gut wir wissen aus der
Geschichte dass wir dass die Dinge in
der Regel wahrscheinlich komplizierter
sind und das natürlich jeder also ich
würde erstmal meinen wenigen da trauen
weil wir natürlich alle auf der
öffentlichen Bühne die Dinge äußern wir
wissen das schlicht nicht ob es die
Möglichkeit für einen
verhandlungsfrieden gab im früher würde
ich jetzt argumentieren wissen wir nicht
aber ich vermute dass war was am Ende
rauskommen wird wird nicht so sehr viel
anders sein als das was bei den
Verhandlungen in Istanbul sich schon
angedeutet hat
es ist ja
vielfach gesagt worden ja ein
souveräner Staat muss sich zwei
entscheiden können welchen Bündnisse
angehört das ist im Prinzip richtig
es
ist aber es gibt Präzedenzfälle
Österreich hätte
1955 den Abzug der Besatzungstruppen
nicht erreicht
wenn es nicht sich zu überwährender
paktfreiheit verpflichtet hätte
Ukraine hat war paktfrei sie war
Atomwaffen frei sie hatte eine ganz
praktische
militarisiert und wir haben seit 2014
diesen Krieg sie können keinen Ukraine
kein Ukrainer wird je wieder akzeptieren
wer Lust zu sein und das wird darauf
hinauslaufen ist Österreich und sich
eine andere Situation gewesen zwischen
den zwischen den Blöcken Österreich
waren nicht bedroht die Ukraine wird
bedroht sein sie wird weiter bedroht
sein und damit ist also glaube ich
aber für jeden Ukraine wird klar sein in
einer solchen Situation der Schwäche
wollen wir nie wieder sein wissen was
passiert ist und damit ist die die
Option eine Neutralisierung oder
finnlandisierung das passt jetzt auch
nicht mehr weil die in die NATO kommen
ist glaube ich ist glaube ich vom Tisch
sondern der ist nicht wenn ich das noch
werde es nicht der schlimmste Fall wenn
eben auf dem sogenannten Schlachtfeld
die Ukraine nicht ob sie nicht die
bessere strategische Position hat im
Westen eine Müdigkeit der Unterstützung
Eintritt auch das wissen wir aus vielen
vergleichbaren Vorkommen der Westen ist
auch nicht so kompakt sozusagen der
amerikanische Westen schon längst der
südamerikanische Westen schon längst
nicht und wenn dann sozusagen der Westen
seine Unterstützung weitgehend
zurückzieht keine positionsgewinne dann
hätten wir ein Desaster für diese sehr
viele Fürsten was bedeutet das für uns
in Deutschland was bedeutet das was
bedeuten diese zeichnen Moment die
Ukraine nicht unterstützt wird sie muss
unterstützt werden sie muss unbedingt
unterstützt werden nicht mit allen
natürlich nicht mit allen zum Beispiel
Kampfjets oder Langstreckenraketen die
tief in das russische Territorium
eindringen die riskieren eine Eskalation
und es gibt immer noch ein autokarten
der über nukleare gefechtswaffen und
nicht nur über diese verfügt auch das
muss man politisch ins Kalkül ziehen
wir müssen aber wir merken schon unsere
Diskussion ist ein ganz viele ist hier
drin und dann merken Sie welches Problem
wir haben weil wir alle nicht
einschätzen können wie ist eigentlich
wirklich das Gefühl von Putin und selbst
wenn man jetzt mal die westlichen
Staaten nimmt immer die
also ich bin ja immer auch jemand
gewesen der zögerlich das kommentiert
hat oder auch kritisch kommentiert hat
aber wir haben ja schon von der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz zu beidens Besuch
in Kiew eine eine ganz starke
Kommunikation ein ganz starkes Signal
gesehen ein
zeichenpräsidentin gesagt hat auf damit
das Konferenz jetzt fährt bei ihnen
dorthin also wenn man das jetzt ernst
nimmt und wir alle wissen nicht was dann
hinter verschlossenen Türen genau
anlaufen Lieferung verhandelt wird dann
kann der Westen dahinter eigentlich
nicht zurück umsichtig voll ins
lächerlich zu machen also man ist so
committed auf die USA die beiden hätte
ja nicht nach hier fahren müssen er hat
aber getan und damit ist er sehr stark
committed und ich glaube dass dann die
Rechnung so ist dass wir die Ukraine so
weit unterstützen und die die dann
hoffen natürlich alle dass die Ukraine
so stark ist und was sie auch in der
Lage sein wird Putin massiv militärisch
zu schwächen ob das gelingt ist eine
völlig offene Frage da wäre ich auch
nicht zu
ich stimme Ihnen total zu und das hängt
auch davon ab wie diese Debatten auch in
diesem Kreisen geführt werden es ist
wirklich davon abhängig was darüber wie
das darüber diskutiert wird und wenn es
aus das nicht wenn es aus der Sicht
diskutiert wird dass Europa weiterhin
geschlossen zusammenhält das Europa eine
Strategie in der sich Hinsicht hat das
ist eine internationale
Sicherheitsstrategie gibt die ich
persönlich gerade nicht sehe nicht
erkenne auf mittel und langfristige
Perspektive dann wird die Ukraine auch
so gestärkt werden können das wäre für
sie für alle das Wichtigste dass die
Ukraine dargestellt ist und ich glaube
für uns alle für uns alle in Europa
aber man sollte nicht überschätzen das
sehen wir jetzt an der Lieferung von
Leopard Panzern wie die Unterstützung
auch zögerlich ja wir sind am Ende
dieser Sendung noch lange nicht am Ende
dieser Debatte leider und ich kann
einfach nur hoffen dass wir nicht in
einem Jahr
wieder über einen zweiten Jahrestag des
Krieges reden lassen Sie uns das hoffen
dass es irgendwie bis dahin dieser Krieg
beendet ist Herr neitzelt
Herr Merkel vielen Dank für die
Diskussion und ihnen vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen vielen Dank
[Musik]